[Music]
we are nearing a grim
milestone in the coronavirus pandemic
200
000 deaths in the u.s it's already
claimed more than 196 000 lives across
this country
including parents siblings friends and
essential workers
we are continuing to share the stories
of the remarkable people we've lost
here are just some of the many lives to
remember
trini lopez scored a global smash in
1963.
if i had a hammer went to number one in
36 countries
the next year in france lopez was given
top billing
with a hot young british band lopez was
born
in the little mexico neighborhood of
dallas but his first label wanted to
hide his heritage
and change his name lopez refused
and was later signed by frank sinatra to
his reprise label
where he had his run of his he became a
las vegas regular
starred in films like the dirty dozen
and also
designed two guitars for gibson that
became collector's classics
trini lopez was 83.
this is clear channel 820 wbap fort
worth dallas texas
bill mack was an overnight dj who kept
long-haul truckers company
go back to midnight cowboy with you all
night long
but mack also wrote songs leanne rime's
recording of blue
in 1996 won mack the grammy for best
country song
and the acm award for song of the year
another mac tune drinking champagne
has become a country classic willie
nelson performed it with him
in 2009. bill mack was 91.
milla handley was a pioneering woman in
the world of wine
the founder of hanley cellars in
anderson valley california
she was the first woman in the country
to establish a vineyard
in her own name hanley produced her
first vintage
250 cases of chardonnay in the basement
of her home
in 1982. she established her style and
stuck to it
said lead winemaker randy shock she
didn't follow
trends she paved the way for other women
including her daughter lulu mcclellan
now president
who said her shoes are impossibly big to
fill
hanley was an avid equestrian and loved
the 1959 mercedes
she inherited from her mother her
favorite times
shock said were to pull the top down and
drive it to the beach
milla handley was 68.
adolfo alvarado jr was a chaplain in
south texas
fito as he was known worked for 30 years
as a technician with southwestern bell
in his youth he was a gambler who loved
the horses
but after an encounter with god fito
became a pastor
devoted to his church and his family
in recent years he'd comforted the sick
in hospice care
until he got sick himself this summer
he was the kindest easiest person to
talk to
said his daughter amanda vare it's kinda
hard to know the phone's not gonna ring
because my dad literally called me every
single day
adolfo alvarado was 70.
erica mcadoo was a senior detention
officer with the los angeles police
department
who in her off hours also ran a catering
service
with her mom she was always the
peacemaker
donna royston said of her daughter
erica had just been promoted when she
got sick
her friends tried to rally her during
her 97 days in intensive care
upon her death her co-workers held a
celebration of her life
at the beach we just wanted to do
something that she loved
said catalina alvarado she so missed
said her mom it's just not the same
without her
erica mcadoo was 38. erica mcadoo was an
amazing young woman
that this is the hard part every time we
do this yes there are so many remarkable
people we've lost
uh to this this is these are literally
just a handful a reminder too of the age
range it's so important to tell these
stories
all right we'll be right back your local
news is next